bitcoin for the most part attracts
missionaries right these are people who
believe in bitcoin they believe in the
ethos of bitcoin they believe in the
future world of bitcoin can create and
they believe that holding this asset for
a long period of time is going to end up
being really really valuable and they
are willing to suffer
all of the volatility in the meantime
from 10 to 64 000 from 64 to 30 000 from
30 000 to 50 000 to back down to 30 000
to wherever we go next they are willing
to suffer through all that volatility
because they believe they are not
mercenaries they are not just here for
short-term profits they are missionaries
not mercenaries and the reason why
that's important is because they are
mission driven and when you have
mission-driven holders you get what is
unique to the bitcoin ecosystem which is
you get 80 plus percent of all bitcoin
in circulation that is not lost being
held by long-term holders who are not
willing to sell and so you get these
supply squeezes that continue to push
the price higher and higher in u.s
dollar terms other assets who promise
all kinds of shiny things or really
really big short-term profits end up
attracting the mercenaries not the
missionaries we've seen this with
project after project after project
where people rush in they make a profit
so you can't take that away from they
are making a profit in the short term
but then eventually what happens is they
move on to the next thing and the people
who are late to buying that asset
usually actually end up losing and so if
you are attracting mercenaries and not
missionaries you are likely to enrich
the people who are early to something
and they will be the beneficiaries it's
the cantonment in effect the exact same
thing that we have in the fiat system uh
those that are closest to the money or
those that are early they get enriched
everyone who's late or who's far away
from the creation of money ends up
actually not doing so well but bitcoin
is different bitcoin has very much a
missionary type holder base and that is
where you see that durability that gets
built into it and so i think that as we
continue to see more and more new things
pop up we're going to continue to see
these narratives that flash up they
appear to be the future there is some
truth to those narratives that's why
there's value being accrued there but
over a long period of time what you
continue to see is that bitcoin is the
most durable asset in the market and i
think i recently did an interview with
william green that we'll be releasing
probably early next week william is the
author of richer wiser happier a book
where he goes and he interviews the best
investors in the world and there's a
couple of key components to that book
things like one understand your circle
of competence right right now crypto is
becoming so complex there's so many
different worlds are you an expert in
dfi are you an expert in nfts are you an
expert in bitcoin are you an expert in
layer one um smart contract platforms
are you an expert in stable coins like
it is impossible for one person to be an
expert in all of these things and to
remain kind of fully on top of
everything that's happening the industry
is moving too fast so you're going to
start seeing fragmentation you're going
to start seeing kind of expertise in the
individual sub-verticals so understand
your circle of competence and make sure
you stay there don't try to play games
where you don't have an advantage you
don't have an edge the second thing is
that most of these investors actually
have very very concentrated portfolios
so if you were to ask a charlie munger
or warren buffett for the most part they
just hold berkshire stock if you were to
look at let's say elon musk great elon
musk he has spacex he has tesla stock
he's got neural link stock the things he
works on he owns no public stocks
otherwise if you look at somebody like a
nick sleep or john templeton et cetera
most of these people they actually don't
have really really big portfolios they
simply are holding the best assets they
can find and they look at it uh and
watch it like a hawk and then the last
thing is that there's this element of
super long-term thinking right 10 15 20
years ahead they're not trying to
optimize for how do i make money in the
next 30 days how do i pick an asset
that's going to go up the most in the
next 30 days instead of looking out over
long time frames and if they
consistently get that right they have a
much better chance of outperforming over
the long term because those short-term
decision makers end up actually
succumbing to the human emotions of fear
greed etc and also it's hard if you have
to make a different decision every 30
days
just in a one year period means you have
to get 12 decisions right whereas if
you're a long-term thinker and you pick
the right asset one time you have to
make one good decision and you basically
just have to sit there on your hands so
it's a different way of investing but it
ends up if you look in history over long
periods of time those who pick great
assets hold them for a long period of
time have concentrated portfolios and
understand what they're doing and stay
within that circle of competence they
end up outperforming for the most part
people say we're in the first inning of
bitcoin let's see where it goes
we will see we will see what happens
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]